you went to Martin Scorsese's house to
ask his advice on directing Chris
obviously every buddy who wants a direct
wants to hear with his thoughts and you
know I'm and you've worked with him so
when you sit down with him you figure
he'll give you ten minutes he ends up
giving you like his whole day or
something right he's like around four
hours can you learn something in four
hours yeah but I mean most of all I
learned what did he talk at a
fifteen-year film school like you know
when you worked with Betty and and Ivan
Reitman right like you're paying if you
want to you have a front row education
and all of this is in education yes when
I saw those people work yeah they'd give
me insight into how they work I would
hear you talk about Ivan Reitman yes I
understand how much you absorb like a
sponge from movies right so so imagine
me for that whether it's Judd or Seth
and Evan whether it's Bennett Miller
Spike Jones Martin Scorsese Coen
Brothers Quentin Tarantino Gus fans in
like who is the best director you'll
ever work with Martin Scorsese what
about the Coen brothers I only worked
with him honestly for two days I worked
with Scorsese for like seven months so
so really beyond that it was just him
talking about my film the fact that he
was talking about my film why is
Scorsese so good explain it to me of who
is a novice it's uh you like chess right
yes okay so imagine if you can make the
most complex chess move with no clock
right right that's like no other words I
could think about it you have four hours
to make your move right okay you still
are a brilliant chess player now imagine
you make an even better chess moved in
that brilliant chess player but you do
it in 30 seconds with the clock going
his choices are quick definitive and
right he's sure what it takes a
brilliant director who is not at that
place yet possibly right even I'm
talking someone a master let's catch a
chess player a master director it takes
him he can fix that problem it's
advanced problem fixing I just problem
solving in 30 second you literally watch
it in his eyes and then solve an
insanely complex issue which directing
is just solving issues constantly is
that what Martin Scorsese told you did
he when he sacked you down for 4 hours
and said I'll give you some of my time
and I'll give you some of my because you
can't teach that that
that's something I just watched that's
right so so what could what could he
tell you in four hours well I don't know
I mean so many things we talked about
what the movie is right so constantly
you're just what are you making and why
are you making this move why are you
making it what are you making and what
is it about and how do you maintain that
tone and that and that reality and that
emotion do you guys ever discuss trying
to please the audience and get a big box
office or is that considered crass this
was to make me nineties to say that was
going for a big box office you're doing
this because you believe in it and it's
my heart it's four years in my life
there's no part of this that is anything
but how serious I hold the job of
director and I could have done it
earlier points I could have done it
would be movie stars and I really want
to tell story that mattered to me